The world's smallest
R environment. Running
R on a $15 computer.
Hi my name is Mark.
I'm the founder of
the R4Pi project
and really excited to speak
to you about it today.
I hope you're enjoying
the conference so far.
The R4Pi project
exists to make it easier
to run R on the Raspberry
Pi family of computers.
It's been possible
to run R on them
for a really, really long time.
But the experience is
not necessarily always
a smooth one.
So the R4Pi project really
aims to smooth that process out
to make it a lot easier
for folks to get started.
We've got full documentation
over at R4Pi.org
and I'm going to show
you some more information
about the project today.
So what is a Raspberry Pi?
The Raspberry Pi
computer is a family
of computers that was
first launched in 2012,
so about 10 years old now.
And they're created
by an organization
here in the UK called the
Raspberry Pi Foundation.
The foundation's aim is really
to improve outcomes for folks
through computer science and
education and things like that.
And the way that
they do that is they
create a very, very
low cost computer.
We started out with a
computer that cost $35.
It's about the size
of a deck of cards.
And then there have
been multiple iterations
of that over the years.
And then at some point they
released a smaller version
of that computer,
which only cost $15.
So now there are probably
three main members
of the Raspberry Pi family.
We'll take a look at those
in a little more detail.
The Raspberry Pi 4
Model B is the most common
of the Raspberry Pi
family at the moment.
It's the newest kind of standard
size version of the computer.
This particular one is
in a nice rainbow case,
but the computer itself,
you can see how small it is.
It's probably roughly
the size of a deck
of cards, something like that.
And they start at $35.
That's for the one gigabyte model.
They go all the way up
to 8 gigabytes of RAM.
There's a four core CPU
at 1.5 gigahertz
It has an SD card slot
underneath for storage
and all the things you would
expect from a modern computer.
So USB-3, wifi, bluetooth,
HDMI out, that kind of thing.
Next, we have the
Raspberry Pi Zero 2 W.
This is the second iteration
of the Zero size computer.
You can see that one is
just over an inch wide.
A little larger than
a stick of gum, I guess
These are the $15 computers.
So there's a four core
CPU at one gigahertz,
512 meg of RAM, wifi,
bluetooth, HDMI out and again
the SD card for the
operating system.
And then finally
we have the largest
of the Raspberry Pi computers.
But that's only because it's
built inside this keyboard
here.
So you can see the keyboard has
similar slots to the Raspberry
Pi 4.
It's basically a Raspberry
Pi 4 inside a keyboard case.
It's important to remember
that the Raspberry Pi is just
a computer.
It's a small Linux
computer, and as such,
works very similarly to most
other computers, particularly
computers using the
Linux operating system.
So what about the
R4Pi project?
What is it?
What does it do?
So, the R4Pi project
provides pre-built binaries
of the R language, first of
all, but also provides a CRAN
like repository where we make
available pre-compiled versions
of CRAN packages.
Now we don't do all of CRAN.
Maybe one day.
Right now we're just
doing a subset of CRAN.
So we're building
somewhere in the region
of 250, maybe 300
packages, something
like that at the moment.
But we're adding
more all the time.
The way that this
benefits users is
that, if you're unaware,
if you're a Linux user
and you use CRAN, CRAN gives
you the source code rather
than a pre compiled binary like
they do for Windows and Mac.
This is great because R
knows how to build them
and things like that, but it
can be very time consuming.
There are often dependencies
which aren't necessarily met
in your build environment.
And so the R4Pi project
builds those packages for you
and then makes them available.
In this regard, it's very
similar to RStudio's Package
Manager, but obviously
on a much smaller
scale. With
those packages available,
it becomes much easier for
R users on the Raspberry Pi
to install those packages.
Installation is much quicker.
And there's no build
that needs to occur.
And from there people can
get started much more quickly
with R itself without having
to worry about all of this
build stuff.
OK so let's take a look
at a couple of examples.
In this first one, I'm going
to log in to the Raspberry
Pi via SSH from an iPad.
So this is my little kind
of desktop iPad setup
that I've got going on.
I'm going to use a
program called Blink
to SSH into the Raspberry Pi.
This basically gets me a
kind of Linux terminal,
but on the iPad -- a butterfly
flew into my office and I
type the password wrong as a
result! -- OK, so we're logged in
and we're going to
run R, looks exactly
like R does everywhere else.
What we can do, though, is
if we look at options("repos").
So if we look at the repository
that's set our default cran
is actually pkgs.r4pi.org,
which is the CRAN-like
repository
that we maintain as part
of the R4Pi project.
So that repository contains
the prebuilt binary packages
that we've talked about.
And when you install
them, it does
what R usually does,
which is ask you
if you want to create
a personal library,
if you haven't
already done so, then
it will download those packages
from R4Pi.org.
Download will take a moment,
so we might just speed
through that a little bit.
Then once the packages
are downloaded,
you'll see that it says
installing binary package curl
and installing binary
package Rcpp and so on.
This is different to what
would happen if you installed
those packages from CRAN.
If you installed
them from CRAN,
it would say installing source,
package, curl and so on,
and it would try and
compile those packages
on the Raspberry Pi, which
can be a very time consuming
process.
And obviously there
are occasionally
build dependencies
and things like that
which we've taken care of for
you with the R4Pi project.
This makes installation
a lot faster,
and then once the
packages are installed,
you can load them as
you would normally.
In this example, you see
the Raspberry Pi desktop.
So this would be
particularly useful
if you're using one of
the larger Raspberry
Pis, Raspberry Pi 4,
Raspberry Pi 400.
And we're actually going to
do some work inside an IDE.
So in this case, we're
using Visual Studio Code,
which is available in
the default Raspberry Pi
repositories.
And once that's
fully loaded, you
will see that we have
the R extension installed
and that R extension
makes it possible
for us to do things like
run individual chunks
in this R Markdown
document, for instance.
So in this case, it's just
running that chunk now
and you'll see that the
results come up in a window
on the side, in a pane,
on the side, I guess.
And you can knit the whole
document from here as well.
So just hit the
knit button and it's
knitting the example
and then once
that's knitted we can go
and take a look at it
and it looks exactly as
you would expect it to.
It's very kind of basic, R
Markdown document, obviously,
but hopefully
proves the point.
Then we can also flip over
to this slightly more complex
example.
This is a really,
really nice ggplot2
plot example that I've
borrowed from the Palmer
Penguin's package website.
And if we just step through
that with control and return,
as you would normally.
Step through.
And then when we go
through the last step,
it will print the plot in
the window on the side.
We're quite zoomed in here.
So the for, kind of,
display purposes.
But as you can see,
when we actually
look at the plot
in more detail, it
looks exactly as you
would expect it to look.
OK in this last
example, we're going
to take a look at a
Shiny application.
So this is the Shiny
application, fairly
standard stuff.
And we're going to
run that directly
from the terminal
on the Raspberry Pi.
So to do that, we
use Shiny's built
in function, which
is just runApp,
so Shiny double colon runApp.
And then when we
hit Return on that,
the application will start.
Now this is only
listening locally
at the moment on a random port.
But if we go into the
Raspberry Pi's web browser,
we can take a look at what
that application looks like.
So, we put in localhost,
the port number.
And there it is.
So it's a Bass diffusion
model visualization,
the application's not
hugely important.
The point here is, as much as
anything, is that the R4Pi
project enables you to
do the things that you
can do everywhere else simply
and easily on the Raspberry Pi
as well.
So it's a standard
kind of application.
There are some inputs
which you can manipulate,
which change the
outputs a little bit,
and that works exactly
as you would expect.
But what if you want to
run that persistently?
You want to run that say
on your home network.
Well, the Raspberry Pi can
help with that as well.
Because of the Raspberry Pi's
low power draw requirements,
they make ideal servers
to run kind of 24/7.
So the way that we would do that
for a Shiny application is we
would switch back
to the terminal.
We would drop out of the
running Shiny application here.
So we'll stop that.
And then we'll run it again,
but this time with a couple
of extra parameters.
So we're going to set
the host to 0.0.0.0.
That's basically
just a way of telling
it to listen on the network
rather than just locally.
And then we'll set a port
so that it's easier for me
to find later on.
Once that's up and running.
We can test it.
We can test and make
sure that that's
available on the network.
So to do that, I'm going
to flip over to my iPad.
And then once on the
iPad, I'm going to type
in the IP address
or the host name,
if I have one, for the machine
on the local network.
I'm using the IP
address here and then
I'm going to put in the port
that we specified earlier on.
And we'll see if that loads.
There we go.
It's the exact same Bass
diffusion model visualization
running in the exact
same way as before.
The rendering is probably
a little different
because we're using the
iPad web browser rather than
the one that's built
into the Raspberry Pi.
But other than that, it works
in exactly the same way,
the same inputs connected
to the same outputs that
change the plots in
exactly the same way.
One of the things that
I'm most excited about,
about running R on a
Raspberry Pi is because it's
a very small computer,
you can run them in places
where you wouldn't normally
run a 1000, 2000 dollar
computer. They
can be powered by batteries.
In a lot of cases,
especially the smaller ones,
you can run those from
a USB battery bank,
but you can imagine,
ordinarily with data
science, people give us data.
So the data is
collected somewhere.
It's bundled together,
often not very well,
and then handed over to the
data scientist for analysis.
But what we can do
with when we have
a small computer
like the Raspberry Pi
is we can put that computer
where the data is collected.
So that could be the data
collection device as well as
the place where the
analysis occurs.
This kind of
concept in computing
is often referred to
as edge computing,
because you can take the
centralized resources that
are often used for
this sort of work
and you can move them to
the edge of the network.
This means that you
can run projects
in a lot more interesting
places than you might otherwise
be able to.
Because of the low
power requirements
of the Raspberry Pi.
You can run them in a
car while you're out
parasending.
I can imagine
people running them
while they're on a building
site or in a digger.
Maybe even a farmer looking
after cows in a field.
In a forest, on a boat.
The possibilities really
are endless with such
a small, low power device.
There are many
different ways that you
could run the types
of projects that we've
talked about here today.
You don't need a
Raspberry Pi computer
to do any of this stuff.
But for me, the kind
of low cost,
the kind of ease of
entry into the ecosystem
is a really big boon for
a certain class of users,
whether they're people
who are just coming
to R for the first time, just want
to learn, people who want to learn
Linux so that they can use R on
Linux because obviously that's
more or less a de facto
operating system
for scientific and technical
computing at this point,
or for any other reason.
Just having something that's
very low cost and very
accessible for folks is a
really nice way to help people
get into the R ecosystem.
Thanks for watching
the talk to this point.
Please check out R4Pi.org website.
Check out the Raspberry Pi
family of computers,
if that's something
that you think
you might be interested in.
My personal website
and Twitter details
are there as well
if you want them.
Thanks again, and I hope
you have an excellent rest
of the conference. Bye.